you want to take a guess ashley um
sure is it michael b jordan
are you michael b jordan yeah
everyone say hi to 2020 sexiest man
alive
michael b jordan i worked pretty hard
for this one
people magazine's annual honor was
announced on tuesday during jimmy kimmel
live
but before the big reveal jimmy had fans
call in to ask yes or no questions to
find out who it might be
and michael well he was hiding all that
sexiness
under a hazmat suit here he is for the
year 2020 people's
sexiest man alive
only michael b jordan could rock a
hazmat suit with a smiley face and still
make it sexy
the 33-year-old actor is the 35th celeb
to receive the title since the annual
campaign launched in 1985.
and yeah i did the math michael wasn't
even born back then
i'm just adjusting to this uh this this
uh this new air that i'm that i'm kind
of breathing in
e.t caught up with the mag's editorial
director kate coyne on wednesday
and she explained why the black panther
star was the obvious choice this year
this wasn't a year in which anyone had a
huge blockbuster film
it wasn't a year in which right about
now anyone has a huge blockbuster film
to promote
or even necessarily a hit tv show
um it it really kind of
wiped the slate clean and in an exciting
way
gave us the opportunity to look at
just you know who's hot who's great
regardless of whether they had a movie
open this year
or have a show go to number one in the
ratings just
who is flat out somebody who we
consistently hear about
time and again as somebody who we ought
to be considering and
michael's always been on those lists
he's always been there
and i think especially when we saw the
role he took
in black lives matter and uh color for
change
it it really made us realize like now is
the time we should just be doing this
right now
i think that there was an overall
kind of adorable very sweet boyishness
to him that people might not
expect and while michael sometimes plays
a tough guy
on screen she said behind the scenes
he's not what you'd expect
he's not the tough guy that fans of
creed
or certainly people uh who who are used
to seeing
his more intense dramatic roles would
maybe expect that he is he's still
kind of uh a young guy
who hasn't figured out dating quite that
that well yet is still
kind of finding his way in that whose
idea of a perfect date is still kind of
going to a movie and and having dinner
he's our youngest sexiest man alive
in in a little bit too and so uh that
really comes through
he's he's a he's a young guy he's a
young suave guy
who um is still kind of a comic book
anime kid at heart in a lot of ways
yeah he might be a comic book kid at
heart
but his six-pack abs are making our
hearts race
okay why ain't mad at that y'all ain't
mad back in 2018
michael opened up to e.t about getting
his body in tip-top shape for his role
in black panther
i'm a naturally competitive person you
know and honestly i just wanted to uh
achieve the look that i really needed to
get for
for killmonger obviously there's a lot
of choreography and you know fight
training and stuff like that but
yeah i mean i think it's a natural
competition to want to want to be
physically you know intimidating and you
know what i'm saying and
be a little cut up i wasn't going for
like the the ripped
boxer look and that i kind of wanted to
be more you know
just beefier heavier more and more
intimidating on this one
yeah no denying he's easy on the eyes
but what
really makes our hearts skip a beat
mbj's commitment to making the world a
better place
yeah it's it's kind of you know thought
out but at the same time it's just who i
am you know i'm just kind of like
walking my path and
just trying to stay out of my own way
being honest they're trying to do honest
work
using my platform however i can to to
make a change to make a difference
tell stories that really matter